Object-oriented programming is one of those things where, there's just so many
reasons to use it that I can't think of a reason not to use it. I think, first
of all, so much of the programming that is done in industry today uses objects
and object-oriented programming. And you almost cannot be in industry without
knowing what these things are. The second reason is that object-oriented
programming really falls in line with the way you and I think. So, you and I
think of a person as an object having a height and a weight and an eye color.
And, all sorts of attributes. And that's exactly how object-oriented
programming works. It works the way we think. Which is why it's great to know
how to use it, because it'll make your job as a programmer a lot easier.